brian stelter had his last show and  signed off with a really powerful speech  we must make sure we don't give  platforms to those who are lying to our  faces  but we also must make sure we are  representing the full spectrum of debate  and representing what's going on in this  country and in this world  that's why cnn needs to be strong that's  why i believe cnn will always be strong  you you viewers at home it's on you  america needs cnn to be strong i believe  the free world needs a cnn to be strong  and it will continue to be  because all of us are going to help make  that happen  the free world  needs a reliable source  so  four reliable sources for the last time  i'm brian stelter  thanks for being with us  that was rough with the with the  applause at the end you got one person  applauding that's bro i'm gonna miss  this guy brian i will miss him